yeah group takes this six night off d7  is deadly  wow  i'm i'm kind of amazed he's still  playing to be honest yeah i think he's  only in this because of the time  situation and also perhaps because  um  yeah he he is having a very bad day and  i think he's coming to terms with the  for all today which must be difficult  yeah yeah yeah he's  that's a that's a big crash that is a  big crash as you see  four straight losses  yeah and this one was an unnecessary one  in my opinion if you had played bishop  takes h3 i don't think he would have  lost this game  yeah i agree  did discuss the earlier one  yeah prank just resigned so indeed this  is now the final  couple of moves  um before  we come to the conclusion of day two of  the adjustable mass